[Music]
it was the largest contiguous land
Empire in history stretching from Korea
to Ukraine and from Siberia to southern
China and was forged on the open plains
in the 12th century CE II before the
Mongol Empire formed the East Asian
steppe was home to scatter groups of
Mongol and Turkic pastoral nomads led by
Khan's the people herded sheep cattle
yaks and camels they lived in felt tents
and moved between summer and winter camp
sites nomadic women held significant
Authority managing these migrations many
of the flocks and trade meanwhile men
specialized in mounted warfare these
nomadic groups often fought each other
that was to change a new Temujin who is
born into an aristocratic Mongol family
despite losing his father at an early
age and growing up in poverty he quickly
rose to power by forging strategic
alliances with other leaders unlike
those Khan's Temujin promoted soldiers
based on merit and distributed spoils
evenly among them his most brilliant
move was to scatter the nomads he
conquered among his own soldiers so they
couldn't join together against him these
innovations made him unstoppable and by
1206 he had United the people of the
felt wall tents and become Chinggis
Khaan the Mongols were shamaness --tz--
believing that the spirits of nature and
their ancestors inhabited the world
around them
overall arched the sky God Tang Giri
Chinggis Khaan believed that Tang Gary
wanted him to conquer the entire world
in his name with the nomads of the
Mongolian plain united this seemed
Within Reach
anyone who resisted the Mongols was
resisting ting Gary's will and for this
insubordination had to die under
Chinggis Khaan the Mongols first subdued
northern China and the eastern Islamic
lands after his death in 1227 the divine
mandate passed to his family were the
golden lineage in the twelve 30s Chingiz
Khan's sons and daughters conquered the
Turks of
Asia and the Russian princes then
destroyed two European armies in 1241 in
the 12 50s the Mongols seized Islamic
territory as far as Baghdad while in the
east their grasp reached southern China
by 1279 life within the Mongol Empire
wasn't just war pillage and destruction
once the Mongols conquered a territory
they left its internal politics alone
and use local administrators to govern
for them the mongols let all religions
flourish as long as the leaders prayed
for them although they routinely
captured artisans scholars and engineers
they appreciated what those specialists
could do and forcibly settle them across
Asia to continue their work the most
valuable produce in the Empire was gold
brocade which took silk from China goal
from Tibet and Weaver's from Baghdad
gold brocade clothed the Mongol rulers
covered their horses and line their
tents the Mongols particularly prized
gunpowder technicians from China with
much of Eurasia politically unified
trade flourished along the Silk Road
helped by an extensive system of horse
messengers and relay posts robust trade
continued at sea especially in blue and
white porcelain which combined white
pottery from Mongol China with blue dye
from Mungo Iran but this was not to last
succession to the Great Khan didn't
automatically go to the eldest son but
rather allowed brothers uncles and
cousins to vie for leadership with
senior widows acting his regions for
their sons by the 1260s Chingiz khan's
grandsons were in a full-blown civil war
over inheritance and fragmented the
realm into four separate empires in
China Kublai Khan's wand honesty is
remembered as a golden age of science
and culture in Iran the ilkhanate
inaugurated the development of new
monumental architecture and Persian
miniature painting in Central Asia the
chaga Taikan eight brought forth leaders
like Tim Moore and his descendant Bob
Orr who founded the Mughal Empire in
India and in Eastern Europe the Golden
Horde ruled for years until a trading
post named Muscovy grew into a major
world power even though the Empire
lasted only a short while the mongols
left a legacy of world domination that
remains unmatched today trace the rise
and fall of other powerful empires with
this playlist
[Music]